this video is sponsored by squarespace
most companies depend on advertising to
inform persuade
and remind consumers of their products
and services but not tesla
you won't see any tesla ads anywhere not
online
not on the radio and not on television
where sometimes companies can spend
millions on just a single ad norway
coming for you it's unclear how much
general motors spent on the super bowl
commercial
but the going rate for a 30 second spot
is 5
million in total gm spent 2.7 billion in
advertising promotion in 2020. that's
actually down a billion from the year
before due to disruptions from kovid 19.
here's the advertising cost per vehicle
sold for the leading automakers
genesis part of the hyundai motor
company dished out two thousand dollars
per vehicle in 2019
whereas tesla spent 14 cents incurring
costs from promotional activities rather
than traditional advertising
so why does tesla not run ads
it doesn't have to persuade anyone to
buy its electric cars
back in the day tesla couldn't keep up
with demand there was no need for
advertising
thank you to everyone that ordered the
car we love you customers had to wait
years to get the car the order
like the 35 000 model 3 its most
affordable model yet
and when they did a million people watch
the handover on tesla's youtube channel
its streamed events frequently rake in
millions of views
well maybe that was a little too hard
the cyber truck unveiled where a steel
ball shattered the armored glass
also apparently helped smash sales
oh man ceo elon musk suggested the
company had received 250
000 orders of the electric pickup less
than a week later
all without having to pay for
advertising still
even events failed to fully explain why
tesla doesn't advertise
musk has gone on the record to say he'd
rather use that money to make the
product
great tesla's research and development
budget has been increasing drastically
over the years
while gm's has been steady and recently
dropped slightly in 2020
it still spends considerably more than
tesla it does own several car brands
however musk's company is closing the
gap the thinking behind tesla's focus on
design
engineering and testing is that if you
build the best car the product will
speak for itself
or have others speak for it free of
charge celebrities and influencers have
showered plenty of affection on the
company
jaden smith showed off his pink model x
in a music video
kanye west has made no secret of his
tesla love affair
youtuber zhc surprised mr beast with a
custom designed tesla
not to mention tesla also receives an
abundance of free promotion from musk's
other company
spacex model x's carried nasa astronauts
to the launch pad for flights aboard
falcon 9
while the falcon heavy launched a tesla
roadster on a path to mars
that event generated a flood of media
attention but the relationship between
musk and the traditional news media
hasn't always been so rosy to put it
lightly
he's criticized media coverage for
example about a deadly crash of a model
x on autopilot mode
or production delays involving the model
3. musk suggested journalists write
negative stories in order to get
maximum clicks and because gas and
diesel car companies advertise with
these news organizations
while tesla does not inferring big oil
plays a role behind critical coverage of
tesla which reporters have denied
you might think tesla would respond with
a slick public relations campaign
but actually tesla got rid of its pr
team in north america although it still
has one in europe
while most companies use their pr
departments to communicate information
to journalists
tesla appears to be cutting out the
journalists in favor of communicating
directly with the public
via social media musk's belief in the
power of social media is so strong
that he once hired a meme maker as
tesla's social media manager
adam kazari had a sheep to thank for the
job he caught musk's attention after
tweeting out a photo of this absolute
unit
when he worked at a british museum it
went viral and for some reason
musk ended up changing his profile
picture to that of the big fluffy fella
which generated even more chatter online
his 50 million follower account on
twitter is far greater than that of the
leading automotive companies combined
he often replies to people asking for
help like the time singer cheryl crow
got stuck in a parking lot with a dark
tesla display
it's not just the rich and famous who
have his attention musk routinely
answers questions from the general
public
in many ways he himself is a walking
advertisement for tesla
though occasionally it's gotten him into
trouble the u.s securities and exchange
commission
sued musk for fraud when he tweeted he
was considering taking tesla private at
420 a share a reference to marijuana
and that funding had been secured
controversial or not
musk puts his companies in the spotlight
without the need to pay for it
it should be noted that some other
companies have employed the same
strategy
starbucks relied on word of mouth to
grow costco doesn't pay for advertising
neither does krispy kreme so tesla is
far from the only brand that doesn't
rely on paid advertising
it does however rely on its website for
sales
you don't need to run a company or be a
business to realize the importance of
having a website
it's great for starting a blog or
showing off your work that's what i did
as a journalist
years before squarespace became my
sponsor and it helped me land a lot of
reporting jobs
squarespace is super easy to use you
don't need any experience in website
building
whatsoever there are many beautiful
templates to choose from
you can try that for free for a couple
of weeks by heading to squarespace.com
newsthink
the link is in my description and when
you're ready to launch use my discount
code
newsthink to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or a domain
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm